hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over a trap in the
evans gambit and it's the poison rook
trap devin's game it starts out with e4
e5 knight f3 knight c6 bishop here to c4
getting into the italian game bishop c5
the gioco piano and then the evans
gambit is pawn to
b4 one of the most popular ways to
attack black playing the bishop here to
c5 now black is typically going to
accept this line so bishop takes here on
b4 and this all sets up pawn to c3
forcing the bishop to move back it can
come here to a5 and c5 the most common
and then pushing forward here with d4 so
white giving up material to control the
center of the board with the pawns now
after the pawn takes here there's a
couple ways that white can continue uh
sometimes you may see the pawn take here
on d4
but after pawn takes this really does
leave open the queen side of the board
bishop to b4 maybe bishop to d2 white
gives up the bishop pair here
it doesn't have as many attackers in the
game my preferred way to play and a lot
of people play as well is just castling
on the king side white's given up
material and so that's the name of the
game giving up material so that you can
have a very strong setup getting more
material involved into the game and so
from here if they wanted to take here on
c3 you could just take back and you can
see
open board state you have a lot of
material developed already you already
have
king
safety so this is a pretty good setup
and so with that black may try something
else they're they're going to be up a
pawn and material regardless you can see
they've already taken two pawns they
haven't given up any material so one way
they could continue is to play d6 says
yeah i don't care if you take this pawn
in the center i want to open up and get
more material involved into the game
because right now they don't have a lot
of material so after the pawn takes here
on d4 bishop comes back b6 doesn't make
as much sense to play bishop here to b4
anymore because you can see there's no
longer check so bishop comes back here
to b6 and then the move d5 now this sets
up the trap but white's really just
pushing forward trying to get an
advantage in the center of the board
here one of the principles that you
learn in chess is always to think about
what your opponent left behind
with their move and one of the things
that white is leaving up
once they move the move d5 is this dark
square diagonal you can see this rook
here on a1
is under attack if black can ever get a
piece to attack now it doesn't make a
lot of sense to bring the bishop here to
d4 because then it would just get
captured you know knight takes knight
takes here and then the queen takes here
on
d4 but there's another way that if black
looked at this and said hey my knight's
under attack but
i can actually just play queen to f6 and
this is threatening this rook here on a1
so if white wants to take my knight
that's fine then i'm just going to go
ahead and take this rook here on a1 so
all very logical moves you definitely
may see this in your own evan's gamut
games especially if you're playing the
variation that i talked about which is
fairly common the problem is this does
not actually work for black this is a
poison rook variation and it's not going
to go well if they take their rook here
on
a1 so let's start to analyze exactly how
this is going to fail sometimes if they
look at this they may think okay well
they're going to play queen 2 b3 and
then they can get their queen back here
to something like f6 and try to protect
the f7 square but white has the
immediate threat of just taking here on
f7 yes remember we are giving up
material as white in the evans gambit to
gain either a tempo advantage or a
lethal strike advantage whatever that
may be you're trying to just overwhelm
your opponent
with a strong attack by giving up some
material and that's exactly what the
rook here on a1 does after the king
takes and we'll also look at what
happens if the king doesn't take then
the king is exposed and white can start
to really attack here queen 2 b3 and
this is very different than queen of b3
before because the king wasn't under
attack now it is under attack and so
maybe they try to stop this with
bishop to e6
okay well that's gonna fail to
knight to g5 there's a few ways they can
really counter this you can see the
knight can't be taken so the king has to
move there's no way to really block that
so if we look at maybe king to e7 not
only was the knight attacking the king
but it's also attacking the square here
on e6 which is under attack by the queen
so i can just play queen takes on e6 and
then there's going to be a checkmate
right there and it can't come over here
to you know king 2 d8 because the pawn
is also there to
to protect the queen for a checkmate as
well so if we come back
another option is after knight 2 g5
maybe king 2 g6
okay well now just the bishops under
attack you just say knight takes here on
e6 yes the queen can now get involved
into the action but the pawn takes here
on b7 attacking the rook rook swings
over here but that's okay knight comes
down to f4 check and this is gonna be a
checkmate as well there's no way to
stop it if the king moves back maybe
they decide not to
come to e7 or g6 they could also play
king to e8 but this is not going to go
well either
knight to e6 taking that bishop
queen two e5
bishop to b2 attacking the queen uh
maybe king queen takes here on e4 but
then knight takes here on a g7 check you
can see things are going to go extremely
poorly for black
you can also at some point get this
other rook involved into the game uh
just does not go well for black now if
we come back maybe black decides not to
take the bishop here on f7 could try
something else maybe king to f8 but now
you can see additional threats here
because after the bishop takes on
g8
they really need to take with their rook
if they take with their king then we
still have the same threads before it's
queen coming here to b3 check and then
how do they really continue they
probably need to come back here to
f8 doesn't make a lot of sense now
player bishop because then you're just
gonna take it with your queen here and
they have really no place to go and so
instead maybe king to f8 and then bishop
here to b2 and you can see that is
threatening this queen here on a1 the
queen is trapped so more than likely
they are going to take with their rook
here on a g8 but then knight to
g5 this does set up for pretty strong
attack with knight takes here on h7 my
guess is if they play it correctly
they're going to play rook 2 h8 to stop
that but then queen to d5 is very
difficult to deal with you can see we're
already threatening to move queen to f7
that is going to be checkmate maybe
queen to f6 try to stop that but then
pawn takes here on b7 bishop takes here
attacking our queen but then we can just
take that bishop here on b7 rook over
here to e8 but then queen to c6 and you
can see whites up in material but also
this rook here on h8 not going anywhere
the king is exposed in the center of the
board it's going to be very easy for
white to overwhelm
their opponent
so early on in this opening it
definitely looks like white has left
open an attack on this rook here on a1
but just know especially if you're
playing the white pieces this is
completely fine because it is a poison
rook you are not worried about your
opponent taking it with their queen
right here on f6 definitely not the way
they should continue black should really
be looking to play something like knight
to e7 um yes it does stop the queen from
getting involved into the game but it's
pretty safe they could also just play
knight to a5 this attacks the bishop
which i think is completely fine you
typically don't want to have your
knights on the a file or the h file
they're just not very involved into the
game but this is going to be fine from
black if you do see this white can just
play knight to c3
yes your bishop is going to be
completely fine because if they take it
you can just play queen two a4 this is
check and then after bishop two at d7
then the queen's gonna swing over here
to c4 so the knight here on
c3 is actually somewhat protecting this
bishop here on c4 although it may not
look like it so that's how you can
attack your opponent if they decide to
play queen to f6 trying to take hold of
your rook here on a1 that is the number
another trap hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video of the poison rook trap in
the evans gamut let me know in the
comments below if there's other videos
or type of videos you'd like me to make
but thank you guys so much for watching
this video i'll see you guys next time